liam hemsworth has filed for divorce
from miley cyrus ET can confirm how is
your life like a rom-com it never goes
exactly how I think it's going to the
actor filed legal docs in LA citing
irreconcilable differences
a source tells ET quote Liam's decision
to file for divorce is sad but in the
end it was never going to work they are
two different adding Liam never wanted
to share Miley with anyone he loves her
and he is far too traditional he finally
realized he just wants to start fresh
Miley and Liam announced their split on
August 10th after less than a year of
marriage to be wife husband and wife
it's the best it's the best the day
before Miley was spotted making out with
Brody Jenner's ex her longtime friend
Caitlin Carter in Italy total stranger a
source told DT that Liam is quote
heartbroken that Miley moved on so
quickly and so publicly adding right now
Miley doesn't want to answer to anyone
she still feels the need to explore
herself her sexuality and her music
Miley has been working in the studio and
wants to blow off steam
[Music]
well that's just what she did dropping a
new single titled slide away which
appeared to be about Liam and their
split after their breakup reports
surfaced that Liam's alleged
hard-partying lifestyle drove him and
Miley apart though a source denied that
allegation to ET now a source tells ET
quote at first Liam wanted to just give
it time
but he finally felt like things were
getting nasty and he didn't want to drag
it out publicly he decided it was all
too much and it appears Liam is leaning
on his family to get through this
difficult time
on Tuesday the 29 year old actor was
spotted with his brother Chris on the
beach in Byron Bay Australia a source
tells ET Liam's family has been
incredibly supportive they are relieved
it's over Miley and Liam tied the knot
back in December hosting friends and
family for a wedding celebration at
their home in Nashville I feel so lucky
to be with someone like her the two met
when she was just 17 on the set of the
last song unlike the luckiest ever and
they were together on and off for a
decade